Guten morgen linus.
Guten morgen tim.
Was mir schon immer gefragt habe sind wir uns eigentlich schon mal begegnet.
Keine ahnung aber du kannst mir einfach mal alle orte an denen du jemals warst geben und vielleicht kann ich das dann sagen.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer zweihundertachtunddreißig corona beschleunigt in schneller abfolge knallen wir hier die dinger raus weil ihr habt ja nichts anderes und nichts besseres vor allem zu tun als podcast zu hören,
und wenn man schon podcast hört dann natürlich laut buch netzpolitik oder.
Natürlich was willst du sonst hören.
Also man wird ja noch ein paar sachen einfallen aber jetzt fange ich jetzt nicht an.
Der einzige podcast mit dem gebrochenen zeh übrigens habe ich mehrere leute bei mir gemeldet das fand ich ganz lustig wir gute besserung mein ziel gewünscht haben,
ich will mal so sagen diese gute besserungswünsche haben enorm geholfen denn.
Ganz zweifelsfrei war der c ja bei der letzten sendung noch gebrochen.
Und inzwischen ist er so gut abgeheilt dass er nicht mehr gebrochen ist vielleicht.
Ein wunder.
Aber der war auf jeden fall.
Das ist das ist das worauf diese zeiten warten auf ein wunder.
Ja du das ist digitalisierte fernheilung.
Du meinst wir können jetzt vielleicht ja auch die ausbreitung des virus stoppen.
Wenn hier lahme zum gehen gebracht werden.
Dann ist alles möglich.
Möglich ok ja das alles möglich ist das dachte er auch die bundesregierung.
Und deswegen wollen wir heute mal ein wenig über aktuelle themen reden die die sich ja schon wieder in die tagesschau gebracht haben.
Tagesschau nicht tagesthemen ich war auch sauer ja.
Der tagesthemen ist natürlich viel kleineres publikum das sind ja irgendwie keine einer tagesschau glaube ich fünfzehn millionen tagesthemen vielleicht fünf oder sechs na ja kann ich besser im podcast machen deswegen machen wir jetzt auch ein.
Ja okay verstehe.
Ne
Du musst das dann schon nochmal richtig vor ort antanzen und so.
Ich habe.
Wobei das pressekonferenz bundespräsident.
Das war das ist das das ist das hauptstadtstudio die.
Dieser eingangsbereich kommst du rein dann steht er immer noch übrigens sehr schön die maus und der elefant deswegen gehe ich da sehr gerne hin,
und jetzt neuerdings mit so einem mit so einem spender sterile kannst ja nochmal die hände desinfiziert ich meine wann hast du aktuell mal die gelegenheit.
Fährt man ja auch gerne mal hin ja.
Muss ich mal richtig zu desinfizieren und trägt die maus auch mundschutz.
Thomas hat keinen mundschutz die sau dabei.
Das ist doch wirklich wo bleiben die guten beispiele.
Ja ja das stimmt der elefant mit seinem rüssel trottet auch überall rum ne du weißt gar nicht was das für für für sprüh von.
Stimmt stimmt stimmt ich war heute das erste mal mit maske im supermarkt und hab's voll genossen und ich habe mir jetzt selber masken gemacht bis ins nee business eingestiegen.
Ich muss tatsächlich wir wollten heute eigentlich nur ein thema haben aber das thema maske müssen wir eigentlich auch einfach mal kurz hier aufnehmen und zwar.
Vorsicht ein vorsichtiger disclaimer ihr hört jemanden reden der keine ahnung hat ja aber von masken.
Aha.
Viren und so weiter ne aber wenn ich mir diese ausbreitung kurven anschaue dann gibt es drei länder in denen diese ausbreitung des kurve erstaunlich,
wenig ansteigt und eines dieser länder ist japan das andere ist glaube ich südkorea und das dritte ist glaube ich singapur und.
In diesen ländern ist es üblich bei dem kleinsten husten was irgendwo jemand geäußert hat sich eine mundschutz maske aufzuziehen,
und ich verrate ja normalerweise nicht wo ich meine zeit verbringe.
Aber in japan habe ich sie schon mal verbracht und wenn in japan irgendwie es heißt es gibt einen corona virus dann haben rucki zucki neunzig prozent der leute so eine mundschutz maske vom gesicht und,
diese.
Diese rede die überall wiederholt wurde in den letzten monaten dass eine maske nichts bringen würde für leute um sich selber zu schützen.
Sondern allenfalls in dem fall dass bereits infizierte personen eine solche maske tragen
die ist doch irgendwie mal wieder klassisch nur aus einer perspektive gedacht weil wenn man wie in japan zum beispiel oder in vielen anderen asiatischen ländern eine situation hat in der in
zum beispiel im öffentlichen personennahverkehr neunzig prozent der menschen so eine maske tragen
dann habe ich ja jetzt als potenziell nicht-infizierte person nicht nur meine maske die mich schützt sondern eben auch die der vielen anderen personen die eine tragen das heißt also eine person mit maske hustet.
Der erste teil der tropfen bleibt in die gesagt die groben stückchen bleiben in ihrer maske hängen.
Und der rest hat noch eine gute chance in meiner maske hängen zu bleiben und ich bin sehr erstaunt wie lange sich in deutschland in auf allen kanälen inklusive übrigens auch hier des.
Des unantastbare christian droste in dem ich jedes jedes mal also selten habe ich einen podcast so entgegengefiebert dass ich wirklich schon so auf die uhr gucke um fünf nach zwölf und denke so jetzt langsam wird's mal zeit also,
nach wie vor.
Entgegengefiebert ist ein schönes wort in dem zusammenhang.
Und also absolut ich meine der ja jetzt auch,
klar zum tragen von masken rät der aber immer noch sehr zögerlich dabei ist und eben sagt so ja das ist eine nette geste freundliche geste der.
So die show und sowas das denke ich dass ich das noch rausstellen wird dass hier die wirkung von masken im zweifelsfall sehr unterschätzt ist.
Na gut man muss jetzt erstmal,
dazu mal zwei zwei sachen also erst mal diese schöne kurve die darum geht mit hier die masken länder sind alle unten und so weiter der grund dafür dass die so weit unten sind sind nicht die masken sondern der grund sind die ganzen anderen maßnahmen
die die sofort ergriffen haben leute sofort auf fieber testen am eingang
gleich quarantäne sofort nachgehen die hatten auch alle schon teams aufgesetzt um halt diese ganzen kontakte so sofort nach zu recherchieren etcetera also die liste ist sehr lang,
diese grafik so mit so einer einfachen korrelation zu interpretieren ist,
glaube ich an der stelle nicht nicht hilfreich ja das andere ding ist natürlich stimmt was du sagst ja nur der der glaube die maske würde,
viel helfen beim nicht infiziert werden ist halt schwierig,
aber du hast natürlich recht und das sehe ich auch ganz genauso es ist halt,
einerseits hilft man sozusagen dabei wenn man selber nicht wenn wenn man selber infiziert ist was man ja nicht weiß.
Weil man ja die symptome erst später bekommt ja dass dass man die wahrscheinlichkeit senkt andere leute oder eben auch gegenstände etcetera in irgendeiner form mit seinem virus zu benetzen,
ein ganz anderer interessanter effekt allerdings ist der da wir ja in deutschland immer noch so dieses problem haben
dass es eben nicht so sehr als als freundlichkeit gesehen wird wenn leute das tragen sondern man sozusagen sofort und ausgrenzung phänomen hat mit,
da ist wohl jemand krank worum es ja nicht primär geht dabei,
dass man automatisch wenn man eine maske trägt auch den abstand bekommt im supermarkt den man,
gerne haben möchte und allein deshalb ist schon cool ne und natürlich ganz hipster style die schicken masken ich habe mir jetzt auch mal eine größere timing davon produziert,
das ist natürlich jetzt auch erfährt eine modische aufwertung also bis vor kurzem kannst du ja nicht nein du kannst ja nicht in irgendeinem späti gehen maskiert,
du bist ja gleich von bullen rausgetragen ja der der drückt er sofort unterm unterm tisch auf den roten knopf und wenn du da.
Berliner späti berliner spät die verkäufer ruft nicht die bullen das bleibt alles in der familie.
Ja ja aber du weißt schon irgendwie also das wäre jetzt vor ein paar wochen noch ein echtes problem gewesen mit einer mit einer schwarzen maske reinkommst und wir
komm jetzt auch gerade aus so in so einem zwanzig neunzehn wo es die ganze zeit so oh ja burka tragen in der öffentlichkeit und maskieren und irgendwas,
auf einer demo gehen und so geht ja gar nicht und so weiter und jetzt gibt das alles um in wie du hast noch nichts im gesicht das finde ich irgendwie auch ganz schön.
Richtig du hast genau nämlich den punkt alle reden hier vom grundrechte abbau wegen corona zurecht aber ich würde sagen das vermummungsverbot das kriegen wir gekippt.
Da würde ich sagen wirklich.
Ja ich bin nicht ich bin nicht vermummt ich bin maskiert.
Autonome aller länder wann wenn ich jetzt ja also das ist doch jetzt hier wirklich mal.
Die gelegenheit haben wir so schnell nicht nochmal insofern ja da muss sich was ändern das sieht einfach auch besser aus und da gibt es ja wirklich auch schicke masken.
In
Na jetzt kann es eher zehn in tokio habe ich noch einen peter maß pop-up-store gesehen ja also peter maße sind die,
ja die man kennt hauptsächlich auch aus den protesten in hongkong sehr schick die so hinterm ohr halten die sind aus einem schaumstoff,
und haben natürlich katastrophale werte im
jetzt im schutz aber die sehen halt richtig cool aus ja und die haben dadurch dass sie in der mitte so eine naht haben wo sie aneinander geschweißt sind haben wir eine gewisse stabilität und hängen nicht wie so ein lätzchen vorm mund,
sondern die sehen aus hier wie dieser eine wie so ein böser in so einem.
Batman oder sowas so ein böser ne der dann irgendwie so einen restaurator oder sowas vom mund hat unglaublich schick ja gibt es auch in allen modischen farben.
Und da sehe ich auf jeden fall jetzt hier potenzial stört auch nicht beim podcast hören insofern können das kann das.
Publikum sehr gerne.
Beim podcast natürlich ne also senkt vielleicht die plopp geräusche aber klingt dann halt alles nicht mehr so gut.
Hast du keine maske auf tim.
Nee ich habe jetzt gerade keine maske auf aber ich desinfiziere danach mein mikrofon.
Das ist natürlich der andere punkt ne ich meine unter der annahme diese maske kann ich genau irgendwie wenige sekunden schützen,
was wenn du jetzt irgendwie eine hass und die da am laufenden band was was ich so eine tasche hast bei deinen händen und so
dann kommt natürlich dann entwickelst du relativ schnell halt auch irgendein herpes oder sowas den du dir über diese maske eingetragen hast weil er da die ganze zeit mit deinen fort fingern dran bist aber
ja zieht zieht euch mal bitte masken an und sei es nur um mich zu schützen ja okay das wollte ich nur mal loswerden.
Ja genau da ist in der in der freakshow die ich jetzt gerade gestern aufgenommen habe dummerweise komplett vergessen habe zu erwähnen.
Ja die können sich auch mal alle masken anziehen.
Ja da waren wir auch alle maskiert ja.
Ihr habt doch fern gefragt.
Ja ja klar aber man man kann sich dann ja so einen lustigen filter einfach so eine maske einfach digital aufsetzen das ist ja da sozusagen jetzt der instagram live video filter der noch fehlt.
Ja dass er einfach während während der videokonferenz kannst du ja dann deine deine lieblingsmaske lustigen clowns design oder so einfach digital draufhauen dann bist du auch.
Das ist auf jeden fall das würde ich auch sagen das ist eine freundliche geste.
Und an der stelle bevor du wieder die fragen kommen was ich mir für eine maske gemacht habe ich habe sagen wir mal ich kann zwar nähen also ich kann auch nähmaschinen benutzen und so.
Also.
Falls mich mal einer fragt was das gebracht hat auf einer waldorfschule zu sein das kriegst du da auf jeden fall mitgegeben und ja ich habe die hongkong,
maske mir gebaut und bin ich bin sehr zufrieden also das ist auf jeden fall die hongkong maß die maske link packe ich nicht,
auf jeden fall ganz korrektes system.
Das ist die.
Die webseite zwar ein bisschen unerträglich weil die die ganze zeit hin und her hoppelt aber man lädt sie einfach am besten das pdf runter und dann,
sucht man sich noch einen schönen alten schlafanzug aus mit einem hübschen muster pärchen oder so
und dann noch irgendwie möglichst einen schönen weißen leinenstoff für innen und so und dann kann man sich da schicken filter reinlegen und es gibt auch gleich in allen größen für
kids und für große und dann ist man so richtig komplett angeknabbert und zweiter aspekt,
den man auch nicht vergessen sollte dabei wenn du selber die maske trägst,
trägt es erheblich dazu bei dass du dir nicht die ganze zeit im gesicht rum finger hast und das dann auch nochmal so ein ganz indirekter schutz.
Tim das wollte ich dir sagen dass du dir das mal abgewöhnen muss.
Alles zu seiner zeit die zeit ist jetzt gekommen.
Also soviel soviel zu zu wir reden über themen von dem wir keine ahnung haben kommen wir jetzt mal zu themen von denen andere keine ahnung haben.
Genau.
Wild diskutiert in den letzten tagen und wochen.
Sind verschiedene methoden des tracking von personen zum zwecke des,
letztendlich nachverfolgen wer mit wem kontakt hatte um potenziell menschen früher zu warnen dass sie,
neunzehn infiziert sind ja das bekommt deshalb eine so große rolle tim hatte das ja gerade schon angesprochen weil.
Es ist eine relativ lange inkubation gibt in der man symptomfrei ist,
gleichzeitig aber wohl schon ansteckend das ist ja so der eine entscheidende faktor der.
Dieses virus türkisch macht ich muss bei der gelegenheit auch sagen.
Mir fällt jetzt gerade nicht genau ein wer diesen kommentar gemacht hatte aber das hatte in einer der februar sendungen,
auch ein höherer sehr früh erwähnt als wir über dieses corona thema noch glaube ich als bruder leicht fuß.
Spitze gemacht haben.
Schätzchen gemacht haben ja insofern dass den kommentar sollte ich dem kommentierenden zu ehren dann auch nochmal in den shownotes haben.
Schreibe mir erst mal noch kurz auf so und um diesen aspekt.
Zu würdigen es ist es natürlich wünschenswert zu früh wie möglich potenziell infizierte.
Informieren zu können dass sie sich bitte in heim ins bett begeben ja und aufhören anderen ins gesicht zu spucken.
Natürlich auch in ermangelung einer.
Einfachen schnelltest möglichkeit die wir alle morgens mittags abends zuhause machen würden oder so etwas so jetzt so hat sich jetzt also der wie ich denke zunächst einmal legitime anspruch entwickelt doch mal zu überlegen,
wie es denn möglich wäre zu tracken wer.
Mit wer wann oder mit wem eine person kontakt hatte und.
Ich denke so man es leuchtet jetzt erstmal ein dass das potenziell ein sehr guten effekt haben könnte,
weil man eben potenziell infizierte menschen früher irgendwie ruhig stellen könnte.
Und die ersten ideen die es dazu gab.
Waren letztendlich so von jens spahn.
Angeregt so eine vollumfassende änderung des infektionsschutz gesetzes so ich will bitte,
vollumfängliches location tracking haben damit ich im zweifelsfall die gesamte bevölkerung,
so tracke und wenn dann wenn ich sehe eine person ist infiziert dann gehe ich quasi deren weg zurück und weiß und alle die jemals irgendwo zur gleichen zeit am gleichen ort waren werden dann informiert so,
die sehr naive vorstellung hier und.
Ruckzuck hatten wir jetzt eine sehr stark eskalierende debatte um tracking die zum glück auch darin mündete das jens spahn diesen,
diese idee erstmal zurückgezogen hat ja also nach,
stand jetzt ist das nicht mehr teil seiner idee für die ausweitung aber er hat die wie gesagt auch nur zurückgestellt und.
Ich würde jetzt gerne mal kurz erläutern.
Oder ein bisschen dabei helfen diese debatte mal zu versachlichen und zielgerichtet zu führen denn das einzige was uns ja wirklich interessiert ist.
Ob in einem fraglichen zeitraum der maximal tee minus vierzehn tage ist,
weil ich glaube üblicher der durchschnittliche wartest du ja eine woche bis du symptome hast also gehen wir mal ein bisschen martin of obendrauf bist du bei maximal vierzehn tage die du rückblickend gucken muss,
wann seit wann du dich potenziell infiziert hast oder ansteckend warst welche kontakte du in diesem zeitraum hattest und,
du brauchst aber auch nicht es ist dafür relativ unerheblich wo du diese kontakte hattest und wann es ist erstmal nur erheblich dass du diese kontakte überhaupt hattest.
Und.
Jetzt werden hier begriffe wie standortdaten bewegungsstark und kontaktdaten sehr wild gemischt also würde ich mal auf dröseln was jeweils gemeint ist also standortdaten.
Bestehen im prinzip aus drei aspekten nämlich erstens person x war zum zeitpunkt t.
An standort a ja und am person x war am zeitpunkt t plus eins.
Am ort b und das wäre jetzt einfach eine reihe untereinander also letztendlich ein gps lok,
dieser person und dieses gps rock hätte jetzt eine sample rate wo man also sagt okay so oft,
wird das abgegriffen was weiß ich alle fünf sekunden alle zehn sekunden alle halbe stunde ja.
Worauf du dich ja jetzt beziehst ist ja im prinzip standortdaten über also die sozusagen rausfallen.
Meinst du sprichst du jetzt von generell oder von netz seite oder von gerätes seite also das was an ein netz sieht oder generell wie meinst du es.
Erstmal unerheblich weil in den daten steht ja erstmal nur ein ort und ein zeitpunkt und eine person,
jetzt stellt sich natürlich die frage wie genau sind diese daten ja beispiel p so wissen wir auflösung ich glaube im zivilen bereich irgendwie so um einen meter.
Wer aber mal in einem raum war sieht dass das sich komplett auflöst ne also ich wohne in einem klassischen berliner haus mit vorderhaus seitenflügel,
und hinterhaus und wenn ich jetzt hier in,
meiner wohnung das einschalte dann kreist im prinzip der dieser ortungs-und bogen irgendwo so auf diesem haus ja.
Dazu möchte ich was sagen also erstmal also die ortung vom netz her also wenn du geordnet wird von außen ist natürlich nochmal deutlich,
ungenauer und die telefone selber benutzen ja nicht nur gps sondern eben im großen umfang auch
über wlan gebildete daten das heißt aber trotzdem nicht dass das genau ist soll man hüpft halt auch mal gerne auf die andere straßenseite rüber et cetera und man ist auch mal eine nebenstraße weiter also genau ist das auf gar keinen fall.
Richtig und das ist jetzt immer noch nur ps und du hast einen wichtigen aspekt angesprochen die ortung an unserem mobiltelefon funktioniert tatsächlich,
genauer dadurch und insbesondere in städten genauer dadurch,
das ist hier so viele wlands gibt denn es wurde einfach einmal sehr genau vermessen.
Und dieses konzept wird laufend einfach aktualisiert wenn wir mal ein gesichertes p signal haben,
welche wlands empfangen wir denn dort mit welcher stärke und das hier jetzt in keine ahnung bei mir im haus wahrscheinlich irgendwie vierzig wlan es gibt die ich empfange die ich alle mit einer unterschiedlichen stärke empfange die für diesen ort
charakteristisch ist lässt sich diese signal genauigkeit durch wlan noch aufwerten aber es ist.
Wird nicht genauer als einen meter im zweifelsfall noch viel ungenauer was aber als kontakt jetzt hier in diesem rahmen definiert ist ist ja zwei personen sind sich ein anderthalb meter oder näher,
also auf anderthalb meter nah und zwar für einen längeren zeitraum von ich glaube das war jetzt hier fünfzehn minuten ist jetzt die definition ja.
Das interessante ist wenn unsere messungen genauigkeit schon ein meter ist dann heißt das zwei personen,
können am gleichen ort sein ja die können sagen wir mal sich sehr nahe sein wie man nur wenigen leuten nahe ist.
Und trotzdem ein signal von insgesamt zwei meter entfernung haben,
weil die abweichungen die durchschnittliche abweichung eben bis zu einem meter sein kann die können sich aber genauso gut,
sagen wir mal zwei meter voneinander entfernt sein oder drei meter,
und trotzdem als kontakt gewertet werden weil ihre abweichungen ebenso groß ist das heißt wir wollen wenn wir nun aus diesen location daten ein kontakt haben wollen,
brauchen wir ja von zwei leuten jeweils einen standort datum und sagen dann okay alles klar.
Die waren jetzt hier sich so nah und der messe die messung genauigkeit schon mit gps ist zu groß um das überhaupt religion feststellen zu können.
Dazu kommen noch die zeitliche auflösung die natürlich auch nicht ausreicht weil ja das auch nicht irgendwie sekundengenau oder auch nur minuten genau gemacht wird
das heißt im prinzip ist jeder der gerade irgendwo an deiner straße entlang geht oder auf der anderen straßenseite potenziell irgendjemand der in dieses modell reingerechnet werden könnte oder rausgerechnet werden könnte.
Du könntest natürlich jetzt die sendling rate variabel machen und sagen ok wir werden wir ergänzen das um zeiträume oder so aber,
punkt ist die die räumliche auflösung ist schon mal nicht genau genug und wahrscheinlich die zeitliche auch nicht.
Genau also wer übrigens mal auf seinem telefon mit so,
aufzeichnungsort programm gearbeitet hat es gibt ja solche apps die so speichern.
Entweder auf deinem telefon oder auch in der cloud google maps hat auch so ein feature diese zeitachse wenn man das mal einschaltet und mal gucken was da so aufgezeichnet wird dann sieht man wie unfassbar ungenau das ist.
Also kann ja auch jeder openstreetmap per sagen wenn die müssen dann auch erstmal wenn sie mit so einem tracker ein paar neue straßen abgegangen sind müssen ja auch erstmal wieder gerade ziehen so,
das zweite problem ist also wir haben sowieso schon mal ungeeignete daten und,
wir haben eine riesen lange liste für jede person denn wenn ich jetzt hier sagen wir mal vierzehn tage backlog gps vlogging mache komm sicherlich obwohl ich mich gerade wenig bewege.
Eine ganze menge datenpunkte zusammen und.
Überwiegende die überwiegende mehrheit dieser daten wäre absolut ohne relevanz denn ich isolierte mich ja hier in der linus ebene ja und gehe ab und zu mal raus spazieren oder sowas.
Auch da finden keine kontakte statt das heißt es gäbe jetzt von mir eine riesen umfang an daten.
Die selbst wenn sie geeignet wären kontakte festzustellen immer noch viel zu viele daten wären.
Und was ich noch hinzufügen möchte wir reden die ganze zeit auch nur von einer zweidimensionalen auflösung ja also im prinzip sind ja alle leute in einem haus die übereinander wohnen auch mehr oder weniger alle auf demselben ort so.
Das ist glaube ich nur in der kartendarstellung so also ps es kann dir auch höhen information geht.
Ja gut aber wenn du in deiner wohnung bist dann hast du nicht unbedingt gps also das ist sozusagen gps setzt schon voraus dass du satelliten siehst und zwar mehrere und das hast du dann in der wohnung eigentlich selten.
Also ich denke mal in so einem fall würde das ding im zweifelsfall davon ausgehen dass ich mich die ganze zeit irgendwo zwischen meinen nachbarn bewegt habe das sind wahrscheinlich in so einem typischen berliner haus hundert personen,
die können dann alle mit mir in quarantäne bleiben erstes problem ist ich habe keine nachbarn mehr die für mich klopapier kaufen können also ihr seht wohin das führt.
Ja das sieht bei euch dann aus wie eine einzige corona party die hängen da alle am selben ort rum was geht.
Komm direkt die bäume so also du hast du hast quasi allein schon wegen der messung genauigkeit sind die daten komplett disqualifiziert dazu kommt noch das riesenproblem dass du unglaublich privatsphäre sensible daten da sammelst ja.
Also so viel ist zu standortdaten zu sagen jetzt haben natürlich einige werden feststellen dass wir uns ich glaube vor zwei drei sendungen noch relativ entspannt dazu geäußert haben,
dass das robert-koch-institut bewegungs daten von der deutschen telekom und ich glaube auch von otto bekommen hat.
Woran was ist hier der unterschied diese bewegungs- daten.
Sind die basieren auf standortdaten und zwar standortdaten die von den mobilfunknetzen.
Generiert werden über letztendlich in welcher funkzelle sich eine person aufgehalten hat und mit welcher signalstärke sie dort angekommen ist dazu ist relevant zu wissen dass eine,
funkzelle immer in drei sektoren a hundertzwanzig grad aufgeteilt ist das heißt,
wenn ihr in einer funkzelle eingebucht seid weiß die auch in ungefähr in welcher richtung ihr seid und die weiß dann auch wie stark das signal ist,
und wenn man das jetzt über einen zeitraum macht,
und ihr bewegt euch dann ist natürlich relativ einfach erkenntlich welchen weg ihr im zweifelsfall gegangen seid,
das klassische beispiel was es hierzu gibt ist zitiere ich jedes mal diese da die vorratsdaten von malte spitz,
die michael krall vor inzwischen ich weiß nicht wie viel jahren damals für zeit online mit seinem team ausgewertet und visualisiert hat wo es dann irgendwie so etwas ging dann konnte man sehen malte spitz fährt mit dem ice von.
Was weiß ich berlin nach hannover und das ist,
zwar sind die daten nicht so genau aber es gibt da nix insofern fährt er wahrscheinlich dort lang und malte spitze des abends zuhause weil er ist wieder in dieser funkzelle eingebucht mit der stärke und so weiter und so fort so,
diese daten,
neben dem mobilfunkanbieter und aggregieren die aggregieren heißt man fügt mehrere daten zusammen und zwar dass sie aussagen treffen können wie,
in einem zeitraum delta haben sich ende personen von,
bereich a zu bereich b bewegt ja man könnte also zum beispiel eine aussage treffen wie.
Zwischen sechs uhr und neun uhr haben sich fünfhundert personen von bernau nach berlin mitte bewegt genau ist im norden von berlin so eine ja,
brandenburg vor ort und da könnte jetzt zum beispiel sein dass es fünfhundert personen gibt die morgens aus bernau nach berlin mitte fahren vielleicht sind's mehr vielleicht sind weniger.
Sowie hanau frankfurt so ungefähr für andere standorte war zum vergleich.
Und.
Diese daten sind natürlich viel geringer räumlich und zeitlich aufgelöst und sollten wenn sie so agiert sind jetzt auch nicht mehr erlauben dass eine spezifische person,
identifiziert wird wenn sie auf diese weise aggregiert sind in die sind,
zum beispiel gut für solche messungen wie wie viele leute fahren denn,
was weiß ich am an meinem werbeplakat vorbei ja wie viele leute sind neu in der stadt bei dieser messe ja und für diese zwecke werden diese daten auch verkauft das ist nicht gut,
würde ich jetzt auch jetzt nicht unbedingt toll finden dass das passiert aber es passiert und es ist jetzt eine,
sagen wir mal für die einzelnen mobilfunk nutzerin noch sehr geringe verletzungen der privatsphäre weil es sich eben um,
bewegungsstörung von mehreren personen handelt.
Wir hatten das ja auch schon vor zwei sendungen schon mal kurz angeschnitten also diese daten werden halt auch für,
navigationssysteme benutzt sozusagen zur einschätzung an welchem tag ist welche straße wie stark befahren was sind da die durchschnittlichen geschwindigkeiten die herausgespielt werden wenn man also noch ein bisschen tiefer in die daten reingrät
und dann eben auch noch so diese triangulieren vornimmt also quasi die bewegung eines telefons oder mehrerer telefone
aus verschiedenen zellen ausgesehen weil man es wird ja nicht
immer nur von einer einzigen zelle gesehen sondern immer von mehreren deswegen gibt's ja auch dieses handover dass man wenn man eine den einflussbereich einer zelle verlassen hat dann eben,
mehr oder weniger übergangs frei von der nächsten zeit übernommen wird und wenn man das halt auch alles noch mit ausrechnet kann man auch noch genauer werden.
Richtig wir wollen aber jetzt mal ganz kurz nur erklären was überhaupt bewegungs daten sind und dass es eben entscheidend ist es gibt einen zeitraum es gibt eine anzahl von personen es gibt bereiche in die die sich bewegt haben und genau aus dem grund,
waren die daten auch so interessant für das robert-koch-institut oder wurden die daten im robert koch institut gegeben weil die ja messen wollen wie sie wollen quasi ein maß haben für wie hat sich denn hier die bewegung
die mobilität der menschen eingeschränkt das ist auf so einer großen ebene natürlich ein ganz brauchbares datensatz sie können also sehen was weiß ich,
wenn du jetzt die kitas zumachst bewegen sich auf einmal weniger leute weil die zu hause bleiben müssen auf die kinder aufpassen und so das ist aber trotzdem natürlich ein sehr großer sehr abstrakter näherungsweise für die,
kontakte einzelner personen wir dürfen ja nicht vergessen in wirklichkeit geht es um,
die kontakte einzelner personen wie viele das sind aber in wirklichkeit.
Was wir eingegangen gesagt haben wollen wir von einer infizierten person die kontakte im,
zeitraum zurückverfolgen indem diese person infektiös war.
Genau also die daten sind an sich wertvoll aber eben für was ganz anderes man kann damit einschätzen haben die maßnahmen die jetzt auf die bevölkerung losgelassen wurden
mit entsprechenden kontakt sperren und bleibt zu hause quarantäne etcetera
insgesamt eine änderung des gesamtverein gebracht und wenn ja wie viel dafür sind sie gut aber eben nicht um,
einzelne personen in irgendeiner form mit anderen in verbindung zu bringen.
Richtig und da kommt jetzt der dritte die dritte art datum ins spiel das sind jetzt eben die kontaktdaten das was wir eigentlich haben wollen.
Die werden jetzt definiert als person a und person b.
Hatten zum zeitpunkt tee für ein zeitraum länger als delta kontakt.
Und man könnte jetzt sogar diesen zeitpunkt tee sogar auch noch wegnehmen ja weil das einzige was wirklich interessiert im infektionsbad zeitraum hatten diese beiden personen.
Für einen ausreichend langen zeitraum kontakt kontakt definiert als sind sich ausreichend nahe gekommen.
Ja das ist das ist ein prinzip sind sich ausreichend nahe gekommen und dann wird eben auf die zeit geschaut
und das ist der einzige der wirklich relevante messwert also weder bei standortdaten noch bei bewegungs daten haben wir das haben wir das da drin sondern versuchen uns das,
irgendwie sehr anstrengend aus ungeeignete daten irgendwie heraus zu kratzen.
Gleichzeitig ist eben an welchem ort das.
Dieser kontakt stattgefunden hat und wo die beiden personen davor und danach waren ist absolut uninteressant wie gesagt es ist sogar uninteressant wann das war warum sollte das also erfasst werden.
Und hier gibt es jetzt eine reihe an sehr interessanten konzepten.
Die es ermöglichen einfach mal nur die kontakte zu erfassen.
Bevor ich auf das was ich für am klügsten halte eingehe würde ich noch kurz sagen dass.
Also eines der konzepte die ich gesehen habe ist,
personen die sich kontaktieren mal am anfang irgendwie gegenseitig so ein q codes kennen ja und dann speichert die app jo hier ne also linus und tim treffen sich dürfen wir ja gar nicht aber würden wir jetzt machen ne.
In einer corona freien welt und.
Dann zeigen wir uns gegenseitig einen qr-code auf unserem handy und speichern quasi diese app hilft uns uns zu merken dass wir uns getroffen haben,
hat natürlich die ganzen offensichtlichen fehler das macht er einen tag dann hast du keinen bock mehr und so weiter und so fort aber nehmen wir das mal ganz kurz als beispiel bevor ich auf die,
auf den auf die bluetooth lösung eingehe die ich für sehr viel klüger halte wir haben nämlich jetzt noch ein weiteres,
problem nämlich die speicherung dieser daten,
die konzepte die man jetzt so von den überwachungs- freunden und freundinnen hört sehen im prinzip vor das zentral,
standortdaten gespeichert werden beispiel jens spahn ideen hier mobilfunknetze gibt mir einfach einmal alles ja.
Wir haben da also diese ganze menge irrelevante daten wo die person überhaupt gar keinen kontakt hat und wir haben,
dsgvo probleme und natürlich dann auch noch für gesundheitsdaten wenn sich jetzt eine person als infiziert herausstellt noch noch weitere probleme.
Also was wir brauchen um so etwas sinnvoll zu machen ist dass die daten dezentral vorgehalten werden damit es keine zentrale überwachung gibt und anonym und zwar auf eine weise anonym das.
Dass du auch nicht nachher anonymisieren kannst.
Und wenn man das jetzt mal übersetzt heißt dezentralität jede person die daten sammelt sammelt diese daten erstmal nur für sich selbst also auf ihrem eigenen gerät und gibt dir nicht automatisiert irgendwo anders hin weiter.
Was auch in den anderen schönen vorteil hat du brauchst halt auch keine zentrale infrastruktur die kaputt gehen kann.
Zumindest keine besonders große anonymität heißt die daten die du über andere personen sammelst.
Sind nicht geeignet andere personen zu anonymisieren.
Und die daten die du über dich selber sammelst sind nicht geeignet dich zu dir anonymisieren.
So also ist letztendlich der datensatz muss zu jedem zeitpunkt an jeder stelle irgendwie anonym sein jeder einzelne datenpunkte du hast es anonym und jeder einzelne daten punkt den du anderen gibst ist anonym.
Und datensparsamkeit würde halt bedeuten,
dass du jetzt nur in dem fall das du infiziert bist werden diese daten ja überhaupt gebraucht wir,
hätten ja jetzt hier bei so einem full take location tracking hätten wir jetzt von was weiß ich sechzig millionen mobilfunk nutzerinnen in deutschland diese kompletten bewegungs- daten und standortdaten.
Und den größeren teil davon würden wir nie brauchen weil letztendlich ja nur die kontakte zählen so und.
Die die datensparsamkeit bestünde also darin dass nur die daten die für eine infektion.
Für einen potenziellen infektionsweg kontakt geeignet sind weitergegeben werden aber auch dann weder die identität der infizierten person noch die identität ihrer kontaktperson preisgeben,
klingt natürlich jetzt erstmal so ungefähr vollständig unmöglich.
Aber es gibt eine wie ich finde äußerst elegante lösungen die viele verschiedene vorschläge für solche apps auch.
Implementieren und umsetzen ich habe das vielleicht fokussiere mich jetzt mal hier auf.
Konzepte die im rahmen des wir versus virus hecke von.
Ja entwickelt und vorgestellt wurden wir wirsing virus merkt man auch dass so eine so ein kriegst du auch nur im homeoffice wo du nicht mit anderen redest und das niemals aussprechen muss.
Schreib's dir einfach in deinen e-mails wir machen wir was es virus und alle so bohren liest sich gut aber aussprechen kannst es nicht oder kannst du es aussprechen.
Wir wissen dass es ja.
Ich muss mich immer zusammenreißen nicht zu schreiben wir sind virus.
Na ja das könnte sein bald ne dass wir das sind.
Aber okay lasst eure titel ist ja auch egal schönes konzept hatten wir ja auch schon hier kurz vorgestellt,
ich habe da jetzt ein paar also ich bin eines der jurymitglieder gibt es sehr viele jurymitglieder weil sie auch unglaublich viele einreichungen gibt und,
da habe ich einige einreichungen gesehen die relativ kluge lösungen gefunden haben,
das alles zu ermöglichen ja also anonymität in alle richtungen dezentrale datenspeicherung und diese datensparsamkeit und zwar.
Machen die das folgendermaßen.
Also wie gesagt es gibt ich kenne nicht die gesamte anzahl an apps die das alles schon vorgeschlagen haben dass jetzt kein konzept was von mir stammt,
und es ist auch kein konzept was aus diesem visa-kurse virus unbedingt jetzt stammt sondern es ist einfach die,
in meinen augen auch einzige sich anbietende lösung des problems insofern glaube ich dass es einfach so offensichtlich und so sinnvoll dass wahrscheinlich gar keine,
jetzt sich gar nicht nachvollziehen lässt werde sich das als erstes ausgedacht hat ansonsten wenn das jemand weiß freue ich mich über hinweis in den shownotes.
Kann ich dir auf jeden fall gleich noch sagen wer sich das schon mal ausgedacht hat aber erzähl erstmal.
Ich kann dir auch sagen dass es sehr viele gibt die sich da schon mal ausgedacht haben aber okay also pass auf funktioniert folgendermaßen das handy,
also es ist wir haben eine smartphonebasierte lösung dieses handy sendet in regelmäßigem abstand abständen einen.
Machen wir das gleich mal so wie es letztlich laufen würde ja also man geht in den app store seiner wahl seiner plattform und lädt sich.
Darfst du ja gar nicht reingehen.
Man lädt mit maske oder oder virus man lädt sich sozusagen die app runter und startet die und die sagt hallo ich möchte gerne auf dein bluetooth zugreifen darf ich ja darfst du,
und ich würde auch gerne noch den standort wissen.
Sie nicht unbedingt stimmrecht diese muss eigentlich nur auf bluetooth zugreifen du hast recht das ist so aber das ist schon mal ein interessanter punkt das wäre nicht erforderlich.
Richtig die.
Wäre aber hilfreich vielleicht.
Nein brauchst du nicht denn diese app macht jetzt folgendes sie nutzt eine,
technologie die nennt sich bluetooth slow energy beacon das low energy gehört hier nicht zu dem bieten sondern zu den bluetooth das ist einfach der neue jahre bluetooth standard ich glaube das ist der vierte bluetooth.
Vier null.
Genau der wurde halt einfach bluetooth flow energy genannt oder biegen und da gab es gibt es jetzt diese idee bluetooth ist ja.
Eigentlich.
Ursprünglich als eine technologie primär angewendet worden wo sich wo sich zwei geräte oder mehr geräte oder ein gerät mit mehreren,
part das heißt was weiß ich ne man meine kopfhörer sind über bluetooth mit meinem,
mobiltelefon gepaart der standard wurde aber eben ergänzt um,
auch sogenannte broadcast nachrichten also nachrichten die du jetzt nicht mehr nur an geräte sendest mit denen du eine paarung ein pairing hast sondern.
Die du quasi in die welt da draußen rufst.
Und das macht dein handy jetzt das sendet also in regelmäßigen zeitlichen abständen einfach einen code da draußen in die welt.
Und kümmert sich auch nicht darum ob den jemand empfängt oder nicht völlig egal das entscheidende ist dass das handy.
Sich aber dafür sorgt dass dieser code sich zum beispiel alle dreißig minuten so nennen ein guter vorschlag,
könnte aber auch alle fünfzehn sein ist eigentlich egal ändert ja.
Also alle dreißig minuten sendet das handy einen anderen code dreißig minuten bietet sich auch deshalb an weil wir ja am ende auf einen zeitraum von ungefähr fünfzehn minuten mindestens kommen wollen,
um sicherzustellen dass wir ein ausreichend langen kontakt hatten dazu komme ich aber später.
Aber die app merkt sich auch diesen code den sie gesendet hat.
Die merkt sich den code den sie gesendet hat beziehungsweise ich würde ja vorschlagen sie generiert den code,
aus einem geheimnis was sie sich ausgedacht hat und der uhrzeit aber,
das ist jetzt ein detail für eine vereinfachte annäherung sagen wir alle dreißig minuten merkt das handy sendet das handy einen anderen code und es weiß welche codes es gesendet hat.
Und meiner meinung nach wäre es trotzdem sinnvoll an der stelle wenn das wenn die app halt auch noch den standort hat dass sie das quasi für sich
verschlüsselt in diesen code noch mit rein speichert oder zumindest separat abspeichert dass wenn man später zugeordnet wird dann auch weiß wann und wo.
Gut das ist jetzt für dich ich würde jetzt mal ich bleibe jetzt mal bei der datensparsamkeit und sagt kannst du machen brauchst du aber nicht.
Okay gut ist für die funktionalität nicht wichtig aber wir sagen wir mal für mein komfort ganz hilfreich.
Ja
Weil ich will ja dann auch wissen was ich.
Hey siri.
Wer hat mich keine krank gemacht.
Lass uns mal bitte kurz dabei bleiben dass man diese standortdaten nicht braucht für dein komfort kann das ding von mir aus auch noch musik spielen.
Du hast recht ich merke mir dass ich merke mir das alles kommt gleich nochmal drauf.
Jetzt in der zeit wo das handy keine biegen sendet lauscht es ob es vielleicht beacons empfängt von anderen handys.
Und wenn es einen empfängt schätzt es anhand der signalstärke den abstand.
Und die reichweite von diesem bluetooth beacons ist sehr gering,
und wenn es den jetzt empfängt und sagt die signalstärke ist ausreichend dann speichert das handy diesen code bei sich und sagt hier ne ich habe jetzt am ende nämlich zwei tabellen in der einen steht diese codes habe ich gesendet.
Und in der anderen steht diese codes habe ich empfangen.
Da sich jetzt der code den ich von der anderen person empfange mit der ich jetzt gerade gegenüber sitze bald wieder ändern wird habe ich keine informationen die mir.
Helfen diese person weiter zu tracken und ich habe tatsächlich auch keine daher keine personen gebundene daten erfasst.
Ich bin also nicht in der lage die andere person längere zeit zu tracken maximal,
könnte ich die andere person dreißig minuten tracken und das auch nur wenn ich ohnehin in ihrer nähe bleibe ja das heißt,
wenn ihr der person einfach so hinterhergeht könnt ihr die besser tracken als wenn ihr es mit der app macht ja hinterhergehen müsstet ihr auf jeden fall.
So zu dem zeitpunkt hat unser handy also einmal eine liste an der an den codes dies gesendet hat und einmal eine liste an den kurz die sie dieses empfangen hat wohlgemerkt man könnte jetzt hingehen und sagen es ist sogar völlig egal wann sie die empfangen hat.
Und es ist völlig egal wo jetzt kommt der schwarze tag an dem ich als infiziert diagnostiziert werde.
Jetzt den waren knopf drücken muss für die menschen mit denen ich kontakt hatte.
Ja ich bin jetzt von mir aus eine woche lang hier von corona party zu corona party gegangen jetzt kommt das böse erwachen ja und jetzt mache ich folgendes ich.
Veröffentliche an einer zentralen stelle alle codes die ich je gesendet habe.
Und man könnte jetzt noch bei einer der apps war das auch bedacht dass es natürlich blöd wäre wenn leute das trollen man könnte jetzt also zum beispiel auch sagen dass quasi die bestätigung dass diese codes,
infiziert sind muss von einer ärztin zum beispiel signiert worden sein das wäre jetzt nochmal so ein extra um dieses system jetzt auch gegen trolling resistent zu machen aber,
entscheidend ist jetzt werden alle codes die ich gesendet habe für die welt veröffentlicht und alle leute die diese app haben laden sich regelmäßig die neuen codes runter.
Die als infiziert markiert wurden.
In den letzten vierzehn tagen.
Ja genau ich würde natürlich sagen also du würdest das eher so bauen dass sie sich,
spätestens täglich runterladen du musst ja davon ausgehen dass das eine tatsächlich eine relativ große menge an codes wäre also du hast hier ein kleines problem mit der menge der daten weil dadurch dass du,
alle dreißig sekunden einen neuen code generierst generierst du ja hundertzwanzig pro stunde.
Also irgendwas um die zwei dreitausend codes pro tag habe ich das jetzt richtig gerechnet.
Naja hängt natürlich davon ab was du jetzt finden finden zeitintervall machst du kannst es natürlich beliebig skalieren und.
Ich habe ja gesagt dreißig dreißig minuten sorry.
Minuten hast du gesagt es sind nicht so viele.
Ja nee genau also du du sendest alle dreißig minuten also zwei pro stunde achtundvierzig codes am tag.
Das nicht viel.
Ist nicht viel aber wir sehen exponentielles wachstum bei den infektionen es werden auf jeden fall jeden tag ein paar neue codes die dazukämen ja aber ist auch in ordnung jetzt du sendest also alle kotze du je gesendet hast.
In dem zeitraum seitdem du die app installiert hast oder maximal vierzehn tage oder seitdem dem frühesten zeitpunkt an dem du infiziert worden könnten sein könntest veröffentlichst du jetzt und alle nutzerinnen dieser app.
Laden sich diese liste der als infektiös markierten codes herunter.
Es gibt also einen zentralen server der hat nur diese codes der weiß aber nicht von wem sind die,
der weiß zum beispiel nicht unbedingt die,
siebenhundertneun codes die ich jetzt hier was weiß ich heute bekommen habe sind die alle von einer person oder sind die von zwei personen oder sind die von drei ja der weiß nur
dieser cord wurde diagnostiziert als wurde ausgesendet von einer kranken person dieser server weiß auch nicht wer diesen code empfangen hat.
Das wissen jeweils nur die geräte.
Ihrer trägerinnen die nehme ich jetzt sich immer die liste der infizierten codes runterladen,
und dann auf ihrer in ihrer datenbank gucken bei den leuten die ich getroffen habe war da jemals dieser code dabei,
und das heißt diese codes haben nur informationswert für die person mit denen ich kontakt hatte und sie könnten.
So sein dass sie ohne ort ohne aussage über ort oder zeit oder person.
Veröffentlicht werden und die die die handys selber das auch nicht wissen jetzt geht also mein handy hin lädt sich zum zeitpunkt.
Was weiß ich am am ersten april siebenhundert neue codes runter vergleich die mit ihrer datenbank und stellt fest oh shit.
Ich habe bei fünf von diesen siebenhundert coachen treffer.
Und die informationen die damit einher gibt geht wäre also nun ich habe offenbar.
Entweder mit fünf unterschiedlichen infizierten personen jeweils eine viertelstunde zusammengesessen oder länger länger oder maximal dreißig minuten.
Oder ich habe mit einer person insgesamt.
Fünf halbe stunden zusammengesessen zweieinhalb stunden ja man könnte also sagen noch nicht einmal das kann aus diesen daten rekonstruiert werden weil dein handy weiß ja nur ein code wurde maximal dreißig minuten gesendet.
Ich habe auf jeden fall fünf davon gesehen es können also entweder
fünf halbe stunden mit einer mit jeweils unterschiedlichen infizierten personen oder zweieinhalb stunden mit einer infizierten person gewesen sein ist aber auch egal weil was mich hier interessiert ist meine exposé,
zu einer infizierten person.
Dass ich diesen code in meinem handy habe sagt ich hatte exporter und du könntest also jetzt in dem moment noch nicht mal aus deinen daten rekonstruieren wer diese person ist dein handy sagt dir aber tim.
Ab in die metaebene du kommst da erstmal jetzt nicht mehr raus es sei denn du musst im krankenhaus.
Also alles wie immer.
Genau.
Und das elegante an dieser lösung ist das auf diesen zentralen server sich wirklich nur diese coach befinden und keine daten darüber welche person infiziert sind,
wo sie sich wann aufgehalten haben,
oder welche personen sie getroffen haben also all das was jetzt hier gesundheitsmäßig relevant wird datenschutz mäßig relevant ist das ist alles.
Per du das heißt du kannst weil du hier keine personenbezogenen daten erfasst.
Beziehungsweise wenn du deine eigenen personenbezogenen daten weitergibst das ja tust,
in einwilligung und in dem wissen dass diese daten so radikal wie möglich der sind desinfiziert sag ich schon der ist jetzt sind,
kannst du es quasi auch rein gewissens tun unterm strich hast du also ein datensatz der besten qualität nämlich nur kontaktdaten.
Und trotzdem komplett anonym und dezentral gesammelt und trotzdem kannst du alle mit denen du kontakt hast alarmieren über diese app.
Für,
die leute denen das jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen zu viel server datenprotokolle anonymisiert aldi krypto und geheim und so weiter,
war,
lass mich mal versuchen ganz einfaches gleichnis zu machen du wirst mir sicherlich gleich ein paar floors in der darstellung nachweisen können aber einfach um es mal ganz einfach zu machen man bewegt sich durch die welt.
Stellt euch vor überall wo er ein wenig verweilt ja wo er sozusagen bei leuten seid legt ihr,
so insgeheim immer so ein kärtchen ab und da schreibt ja immer so irgendein neu ausgedacht das wort drauf bezaubert hinter,
und nach einer bestimmten zeit.
Verschwindet diese tinte auch wieder und die karte ist sozusagen nicht dich und genauso wo du dich dann ebenso aufhältst kannst du solche kärtchen eben auch entsprechend einsammeln.
Und wenn dann halt später sich herausstellt dass irgendjemand der diese kärtchen verteilt hat irgendwie befallen ist von diesem virus da werden halt all diese kärtchen die alle diese worte die auf diese kärtchen drauf geschrieben hat
in den letzten zwei wochen werden dann irgendwie in der zeitung veröffentlicht und da kann man das dann nachschlagen und sieht man was das kälbchen das habe ich doch gesehen so und dann weiß man man war halt in der nähe dieser person,
das ist eine sehr einfache darstellung aber es macht im prinzip die denkweise dieses prinzip erstmal klar dein telefon signalisiert die ganze zeit so hier war jemand
dann und dann
so und wer das in dem moment gehört hat merkt sich das und wenn dann halt zwei wochen später oder maximal zwei wochen später klar wird ist es wichtig sich genau an diesem moment nochmal zu erinnern dann kriegt man das über das internet einfach in die app reingesteckt und die fängt an
brot zu leuchten und damit geht man dann zum test und sagt hier app hat gesagt ich soll mir mal testen lassen test mich mal und schon hast du das stäbchen im hals.
Aber so kann man dann eben doch ganz gut nachvollziehen was passiert ist und man hat jetzt nicht,
unmittelbaren schaden davon wenn man's nicht benutzt aber man hat halt unter umständen etwas davon wenn man's benutzt aber man hat auch keinen nachteil davon wenn man's benutzt zumindest keinen nachteil in datenschutz rechtlicher hinsicht und die ganze,
infrastruktur dafür ist auch verhältnismäßig einfach man muss eigentlich nur eine app ordentlich machen und so ein ziemlich überschaubares backend dafür bauen
für diese ganzen datenaustausch und eben dass es auch trollfest ist wie du schon richtig
gesagt hast man muss natürlich verhindern dass jetzt einfach irgendwelche leute sich da irgendwie durch menschenmassen durchlaufen und dann ja ich bin infiziert ich bin infiziert in die in die welt schreien das muss natürlich in irgendeiner form
sichergestellt sein dass bevor diese daten veröffentlicht werden da eben auch jemand mal drauf geschaut hat und gesagt hat okay das ist jetzt hier auch wirklich ein vorfall der,
der war es so und der stattgefunden hat und wir signieren das dann entsprechend ab.
Also ich meine jetzt einfacher angriff auf ein solches system wäre ich mit dem handy was nicht alle,
dreißig minuten sein code ändert sondern alle drei alle sekunde ja dann kann ich also in dreißig minuten ein.
Vielzahl an codes aussenden und wenn ich dann diese vielzahl an codes als infiziert markiere,
das sind menschen die nur wenige sekunden in meiner nähe waren denken dann sie wären länger in meiner in meiner nähe gewesen ja aber das sind alles sage ich mal details wir wollen ja gerade über das datenschutz und privacy konzept hier reden und,
da denke ich hatte hat dieses konzept eine sehr große eleganz dadurch dass eben die öffentlich verfügbaren informationen nur für diejenigen.
Interpretierbar sind die sie angehen.
Und das ist schon eine sehr eine sehr elegante lösung ja sind wie gesagt relativ viele drauf gekommen ich habe in dem,
wir virus hackerthon vier gesehen die das gemacht haben ich hatte dann auch schon,
angeregt dass diese gruppen sich doch verein sollen das haben sie aber glaube ich schon gemacht bevor die überhaupt jemals diese anregung gehört haben was ich selber verstanden haben dass sie viermal an dem ein sehr ähnlichen konzept arbeiten und in der lage sind durch gebündelt ihrer kräfte das schneller zu erreichen.
Und man könnte jetzt sogar noch sagen ok pass auf wer jetzt kein smartphone hat könnte noch so einen code mit sich rumschleppen.
Und dann wird eben nicht der inhalt des qr-codes gespeichert sondern
auf den qr-code nochmal eine operation angewendet ja das hätte natürlich wer jetzt das wäre dann nur für die leute die kein smartphone haben aber trotzdem mitmachen wollen die könnten natürlich nicht informiert werden aber
also es wäre jetzt irgendwie sogar noch so ein vorarlberg denkbar.
Ich will nochmal kurz sagen warum es relativ wichtig finde dass diese app tatsächlich auch den standort ermittelt.
Erstmal ist es ja wie mit allen apps den du sozusagen standort gibt also solange dieser standort nicht nach außen gelassen wird ist es erstmal okay
ja das heißt es geht darum dass du für dich selber zu speichern und in dem moment wo die app halt auch noch den standort hätte könnte sie eben mit jedem empfangen denn bieten
mit jedem empfangen einen code auch noch den ort und die zeit abspeichern,
hat natürlich den großen vorteil dass wenn du jetzt diese informationen bekommst person x die du nie kennen wirst stand mal in deiner nähe dass du in dem moment halt weißt.
An dem tag an dem ort,
und das kann halt jetzt irgendwo auf dem platz auf der straße in der öffentlichkeit im supermarkt gewesen sein da hilft dir das dann auch nicht groß weiter außer dass du,
einschätzen kannst wie gefährlich ist wohl ist sichern solchen orten aufzuhalten aber es könnte ja auch sein dass es eben irgendein treffen mit freunden gewesen ist und dass du dann in dem moment auch alle anderen warnen kannst,
die an diesem treffen teilgenommen haben die jetzt vielleicht nicht mit dieser app rumgelaufen sind weil die natürlich dann auch potentiell davon
betroffen sind also insofern wäre der nutzen schon erheblich und wenn man die app halt ordentlich programmiert und diesen standort natürlich nicht mit hochlädt also nicht in lesbarer form zumindest sehe ich da halt auch kein problem auch wenn es
immer gut ist natürlich maximal daten sparsam zu sein aber an der stelle sind das meiner meinung nach einfach daten die einfach dann sehr sinnvoll wären.
Also bei mir wäre das zum beispiel jetzt denkbar ne also gestern.
Mit dem bin ich spazieren gegangen laufe ich irgendwie weg lang zu meiner körperlichen ertüchtigung und.
Kommt eine joggerin entgegen seelen ruhiger weg hundert meter geradeaus fünfhundert meter geradeaus weit und breit keine sau ja.
Und die läuft und läuft und läuft und läuft und läuft mir entgegen ich laufe hier entgegen und genau in dem moment wo wir uns begegnen hustet die.
Da wäre natürlich jetzt in der app sehr gut zu sehen ja dann wüsste ich wenigstens dass sie das auch wirklich wahr ja die hat mich infiziert aber ich wusste immer noch nicht genau wer es ist ja aber ich wüsste wenigstens wo ich hier auflauern muss.
Dann verbringst du den nächsten tage da in der ecke.
Bei der bei der nächsten pandemien bei den nächsten panik.
Noch ein noch ein hinweis wohl eine,
ähnlich gelagerte technik bereits heute zum einsatz kommt das ist nämlich bei allen geräten von apple es gibt ja diese schöne funktion mit feind device,
und,
das funktioniert mittlerweile auch so dass auch geräte von dem man halt nicht mehr weiß wo man sie hingelegt hat ja du hast irgendwie dein laptop,
was weiß ich irgendwo mit auf eine party mitgenommen und dann da in der sofaritze liegen lassen oder dein telefon und dann stellst du halt später feste
so und jetzt kannst du aber vorher dein gerät entsprechend registriert haben das ist sozusagen mit deinem account verknüpft ist und jetzt kannst du irgendwie dein telefon fragen wo bist du denn und das gerät.
Ist aber zugeklappt und nicht aktiv im betrieb trotzdem können halt die geräte.
Wenn ich mein telefon zuklappe wird das auch nie wieder in betrieb kommen ja aber okay.
Laptop ist dann halt irgendwie aus,
so das deswegen benutze ich jetzt auch bewusst dieses beispiel aber die modernen laptops sind halt in der lage auch in diesem zuge geklappten zustand immer noch so ein becken auszusenden das heißt alle naselang machen die halt piep,
mit so einem bluetooth code und dann ist es dasselbe prinzip da wird so einen code der sich permanent ändert ausgesendet.
Und wenn andere apple die weißes den höheren leiten sie den ohne zu wissen worauf der zeigt,
an und da ist es natürlich jetzt ein anderes prinzip ja aber von der,
technik die sie zum einsatz kommt es halt vergleichbar an den apple server weiter und die können dann sozusagen zuordnen a das gehört zu dieser idee und wenn ich dann sage wo ist mein laptop geblieben dann sagen die ja hier standortdaten da zack,
und also die verwenden sozusagen dieselbe technologie und auch ähnliche prinzipien mit sich permanent ändern und kurz damit eben niemand der dieses birken sieht weiß
was das ist und das was da auch ist und dann kriegt er auch keine angezeigt mit da liegt ein laptop im
im sofa sondern es läuft einfach alles um hintergrund man benutzt quasi alle anderen telefone und geräte einfach so als datenstaus absauger ohne dass die wissen was sie da machen das heißt es ist auch technik
von der ich mir sehr wohl vorstellen könnte dass sie relativ zeitnah mindestens bei apple tendenziell auch,
in andere telefone einzug halten könnte,
dass man also zumindest die basis dafür die technische basis in irgendeiner form liegt oder es einfacher macht so ein tracking durchzuführen.
Die technische basis achso also die technische basis wäre jetzt hier tatsächlich einfach nur der bluetooth energy standard mit den mit der biegen funktionalität aber ja du kannst das,
es ist jetzt nicht besonders schwierig eine app irgendwie zu bauen die solche biegen sendet und du hast halt die funktionalität im hause.
Es ist natürlich eine eine kleine herausforderung dann dafür zu sorgen dass diese app auch immer im hintergrund läuft und immer aktiv sein kann et cetera wenn einem das sozusagen das betriebssystem übernehmen würde wer schon mal bei.
Das ist wahrscheinlich sogar das größte problem was kein problem ist bin ich von mehreren leuten gefragt worden ja aber dann muss ich doch dann verbinden sich die geräte die ganze zeit per bluetooth mit was anderem und ich habe gehört ich soll bluetooth aus meiner mit meinem gerät sicherer ist.
Also es ist natürlich nicht auszuschließen dass ich in dem bluetooth,
eures handys irgendwo eine schwachstelle befindet die aus nutzbar ist es ist allerdings dann doch relativ unwahrscheinlich dass ihr ausgerechnet darüber gewohnt werdet ja.
Die entscheidende sache bei wird etwas gehackt oder nicht ist im prinzip.
Die komplexität wie mit daten umgegangen wird und was wir hier hätten wir hätten eine einfache broadcast nachricht das handy sendet die also,
so oder so und reagiert.
Quasi nicht auf irgendeine antwort also dass das protokoll ist so so unter komplex wie es nur sein kann nämlich ich sende ein bieten aus mir ist völlig egal es muss auch keine antworten ich sende den einfach.
Jede zeiteinheit und damit endet auch das protokoll ja man würde natürlich diesen biegen jetzt generieren im üblicherweise würde man sich jetzt irgendwie ein geheimnis nehmen und eine ableitung funktion die aus der uhrzeit.
Dem geheimnis ein jeweiligen bieten macht dann ändert er sich eben auch alle halbe stunde oder eine halbe minute oder was auch immer wieder jetzt festlegen.
Die empfangsraum richtung ist auch nur ich empfange den bieten das sind ein paar beide mit denen muss ich nichts anderes machen,
als sie in meine datenbank speichern auch das eine okay sorry,
empfangene daten in eine datenbank speichern ist etwas was seit vielen jahrzehnten von leuten falsch gemacht,
nennt sich aber gehen wir mal davon aus dass die programmierer,
das jetzt mal auf die kette gekriegt haben dann wäre auch hier die angriffs- oberfläche ebenso gering wie sie nur sein kann ja also es wird jetzt es wäre ja keine komplexeren weiteren verarbeitung auf diese daten,
durchgeführt das heißt wir hätten hier ein protokoll einfacher und mit geringerer angriffs- oberfläche kannst du das gar nicht mehr machen.
Und es hat nichts mit pairing oder bluetooth cranking oder mein bluetooth-gerät ist jetzt sichtbar zu tun alle diese funktionen vor denen euch vor zwanzig jahren mal gesagt wurde das ist aber jetzt falsch sondern es ist wirklich,
ein ein broadcast bieten der jetzt mit verschlüsselung und sonstigen scherzen überhaupt nichts zu tun hat es ist quasi eine,
andere funktionalität modernerer bluetooth standards auch mal einfach einfach was zu senden und einfach mal was zu empfangen.
Insofern die angriffsfläche die hier entsteht halte ich für äußerst äußerst gering.
Aufgrund der absolut geringen komplexität dieses gesamte protokoll ist halt nichts damit zu tun dass ihr irgendwie pairing bereit seid auf euren bluetooth-gerät oder auch das senden dieser beacons
wird relativ wenig strom verbrauchen ich weiß nicht genau wie es mit dem empfang ist ja also es,
könnte durchaus sein dass das empfang dieser beacons durchaus ein bisschen strom verbraucht aber,
auf jeden fall nicht so viel dass das gerät jetzt unbrauchbar wird es gibt eine reihe an.
Bemerkungen die ich dazu noch kurz machen muss es gibt minimale änderungen die man an diesem konzept machen könnte.
Wodurch dass eben nicht mehr dieser dezentralität und anonymität entsprechen würde beispielsweise wenn ich sage ich ändere den code nicht regelmäßig.
Schon habe ich location tracking über mehrere orte und tage und habe letztendlich mein handy in einen peilsender verwandelt.
Oder,
wenn ich sage die daten werden jetzt nicht dezentral gespeichert wer weiß wie viele leute ihr handy irgendwie hinfallen lassen oder so sondern wir schicken dir mal lieber direkt an den server
schon hätte ich nämlich eine zentrales zentrales tracking von auch nicht infizierten personen.
Und natürlich wird ja hier auch diskutiert das ist eine frage die mir von den journalistinnen in dem bereich viel gestellt wurde ja kann das denn aber klappen wenn es freiwillig ist meine antwort darauf wäre,
es kann nur klappen wenn es freiwillig ist,
und es kann auch nur klappen wenn es so daten sparsam wie möglich ist denn würde man jetzt eine andere art von app machen die irgendwie auch nur ein bild an daten irgendwo speichert oder hin sendet was nicht notwendig ist.
Insbesondere an andere sendet was nicht notwendig ist dann könnt ihr eure app braucht ihr gar nicht erst zu programmieren wird sich,
aus guten gründen ohnehin niemand installieren insofern.
Entscheidender faktor nur freiwillig und nur in der höchsten anonymität und datensparsamkeit kann aus so einer etwas werden es gibt eine reihe an,
noch verbesserungen dafür zu sorgen dass daten vielleicht trotzdem schon mal verschlüsselt irgendwohin geleitet werden und du erst am ende quasi.
Den kita zu freigibst das sind alles interaktionen die dieses konzept.
Vielleicht ein bisschen stabiler machen,
vielleicht auch verbessern die aber an den grundfragen der anonymität nichts verbessern oder nichts ändern nichts verschlechtern und nichts verbessern deswegen würde ich es jetzt mal im rahmen der einfachheit.
Hier an dieser stelle nicht diskutieren.
Jetzt natürlich die frage wer hat jetzt die autorität und die entscheidungsmacht um dieses projekt auch durchzuführen weil es ist ja auch klar es dürfte nur eine.
Geben es macht keinen sinn wenn jetzt zehn verschiedene korona tracking apps rauskommen weil es würde im zweifelsfall nur dazu führen
dass sie alle in kompatibel zueinander sind alle nicht die notwendige aufmerksamkeit bekommen etcetera,
und es wäre natürlich auch sinnvoll dafür zu sorgen dass diese app möglichst schnell fehlerfrei ist,
weil man kann jetzt auch nicht davon ausgehen wenn die app releast wird dass da schon alles stimmt da kann sein dass irgendwie
was mit der anonymität daneben geht da kann sein dass irgendwie daten falsch übermittelt werden dass sie später nicht zugeordnet werden können dass die ganzen daten sozusagen nutzlos werden sicherheits-
allgemeiner art und natürlich das typische bedient das funktioniert das auch crashers nicht etcetera p p mit worten ein
hoher bedarf an eine hohe qualität und wo wirklich mal viele augen sehr schnell drauf schauen müssen meine auffassung nach kann so eine app nur.
Open source entwickelt werden denn die muss sozusagen da darf an sich kein geheimnis drin sein sonst,
ist es irgendwie vorbei die app muss das richtige tun auf die richtige art und weise und durch dieses richtige funktionsprinzip sicher sein und nicht weil da irgendwas
drin ist was keiner sehen darf und wenn es dann einer sieht denn es ist nicht mehr sicher
und auf der basis ließe sich das halt schon entwickeln von daher wäre es halt eigentlich ganz sinnvoll wenn man jetzt,
zum beispiel diese ganzen teams die mehr oder weniger dieselbe idee verfolgen zusammenschweißt und auch noch andere leute mit einsteigen konsequentes ding in der öffentlichkeit entwickelt das ding konsequent auch in der öffentlichkeit testet.
Erstmal so einen testlauf macht keine ahnung denn es muss ja jetzt auch nicht sein also diese diese app ist ja gar nicht mal nur.
Nützlich jetzt.
Also sie wäre es jetzt auch schon gar keine frage aber sie wird noch sehr viel nützlicher werden unter dem aspekt dass wir ja,
diese lok down situation auch möglichst schnell wieder beenden wollen und wir alle ein großes interesse daran haben,
unsere freiheit wieder zurück zu erlangen ein wirtschaftsbetriebe wieder hinzubekommen und eben möglichst viel von dem wieder tun zu können.
Was wir bisher immer getan haben,
ohne uns erneut zu gefährden weil es ist ja klar in dem moment wo wir anfangen die schulen wieder aufzumachen die kitas wieder aufzumachen die bars wieder zu eröffnen tanzveranstaltungen haben stammkneipen geöffnet werden etcetera und diese ganze nähe
wieder ermöglicht wird und dann wahrscheinlich auch von vielen leuten gesucht wird müssen wir natürlich.
Unheimlich aufpassen dass wenn ich sofort wieder in dieselbe scheiße reinkommen sprich genau dann ist es extrem wertvoll wenn möglichst jedes telefon diese app fährt das könnte zu der meist installierten und meist benutzten app,
ever werden und dass die dann quasi aktiv ist und in dem moment wo jemand sich infiziert.
Man sehr sehr sehr schnell an die leute die informationen heran bringt hier du könntest theoretisch gefährdet sein.
Begib dich mal in untersuchung.
War schön draußen tut uns leid du musst wieder.
Ja aber das das hätte dann die möglichkeit dem sehr schnell her zu werden das zu container,
ohne gleich wieder sagen zu müssen sorry wir haben keinen überblick und wir wissen nicht wo der virus überall lauert,
ihr wisst alle wieder in die hütte und dann kostet das wieder aber millionen und ballons und was nicht alles weil das ist jetzt sicherlich ein zustand die wir in der form nur genau ein einziges mal machen können,
deswegen ist ja auch sinnvoll ihm jetzt erstmal so lange durchzuhalten wie es auch nur irgendwie durchzuhalten ist dann,
umzuschalten in einen modus ok wir versuchen wieder unser normales leben zu leben aber wir wissen alle dass wenn wir.
Beide ziele erreichen wollen nämlich auf der einen seite diesen angriff quasi kontrollierbar zu halten.
Und aber trotzdem in stellung zu sein bis es wirklich dann mal zu einer kompletten durchsurchung gekommen ist weil irgendwie müssen wir den virus verbreiten nur eben nicht so schnell das heißt im umkehrschluss,
das ist ein zustand der muss zwei oder drei jahre anhalten,
und deswegen ist es fast das beste überhaupt mit so einer app rumzulaufen in der tasche um dann eben so ein alarmsystem zu haben um immer sofort sagen zu können ok hier ist uns mal wieder einer durchgerutscht da müssen wir gucken da müssen wir container,
es ist nicht so schlimm das jetzt unbedingt leute krank geworden sind das wird ohnehin passieren
wichtig ist nur dass es nicht zu viele gleichzeitig sind damit das gesundheitssystem mitkommt und dass wir auch insgesamt den prozess verlangsamen können
um den wettlauf zu einer therapie zu einem medikament etcetera alles was sich da demnächst hoffentlich bald ergeben wird
um den wettlauf eben nicht zu verlieren.
Ich würde jetzt nur noch anmerken dass ich von der hoffnung ausgehe dass das nicht.
Am ende drei jahre sind sondern dass wir den drops am ende innerhalb eines jahres gelutscht kriegen weil trump hat ja jetzt auch schon die heilung versprochen.
Hallo.
Und insofern türmen sich das nicht.
Zeitlich nicht so dramatisch wie du aber wer weiß.
Es wird es wird es wird,
mindestens ein jahr wenn ich zwei jahre dauern bis wir eine durch solche grad von von siebzig achtzig prozent haben wo man sagen kann das problem regelt sich jetzt von alleine also es kann nicht mehr zu dieser kolossalen exponentiellen ausbreitung kommen.
Ja gut ich bin mir jetzt nicht so sicher ob wir jetzt uns hier in epidemiologische diskussionen.
Ich gebe da jetzt nur nur nur nur weiter was was bisher sind die einschätzung der epileptologen ist also dass wenn siebzig achtzig prozent erreicht ist
wenn also siebzig prozent der gesellschaft den virus gehabt haben und dagegen immun sind dann wird die ausbreitung nicht mehr so schnell stattfinden können wie wir es derzeit befürchten so aber der
zeitpunkt selber der liegt halt noch in weiter ferne.
Okay jetzt bin ich gespannt es gäbe also jetzt endlich mal ein.
Vorschlag hinter denen,
der größere teil der datenschützer oder ich glaube die datenschützer sowieso ich habe jetzt gerade noch eine sendung gesehen würde ich über twitter darauf hingewiesen aktuelle stunde wo.
Auch der ulrich kelber der datenschutzbeauftragte sich dazu äußert was eben die rahmenbedingungen für so eine,
app wären die das akzeptabel machen würden erteilt da die ansicht,
ich habe dann auch ja später auch durch twitter wir fahren dass es auf netzpolitik org gestern abend auch ein,
artikel veröffentlicht wurde indem wir ebenfalls dieses konzept dargestellt und gelobt wird.
Wir haben,
jetzt im wir wirsing irgendwie ansätze das umzusetzen und jetzt stehen endlich mal alle zeichen in die richtung einer,
datenschutz freundlichen app und ich muss wirklich sagen das ist.
Nicht häufig so dass sich eine derartig kluge datensammlung.
Ohne zentrale überwachung so kompromisslos realisieren lässt ja also man hätte jetzt hier ja dürfen wir nicht vergessen am ende die daten der höchsten qualität nämlich.
Zwei personen nur die kontaktdaten und nur die relevanten kontaktdaten werden sie trotzdem vollständig anonym und dezentral die zentral gesammelt und veröffentlichen informationen sind,
vollständig an und vollständig anonymisiert und wir könnten quasi.
Mit einer zentralisiertes massenüberwachung.
Noch nicht einmal ein so gutes ergebnis bekommen ja also eine zentralisierte massenüberwachung würde ich hatte es ja eingangs ausgeführt zu schlechteren ergebnissen führen und das ist jetzt schon tatsächlich.
Ja nicht häufig so dass man eine so krasse überlegenheit auch von radikaler anonymisierung hat.
Insofern fände ich das schon wirklich würde mich das echt mit großer freude füllen wenn das in der form,
gemäß dieser prinzipien umgesetzt würde und ich hätte dann auch keine bedenken eine solche app zu installieren ich denke dann wird es auch vielen menschen ähnlich gehen.
Das ist nicht häufig so dass dass sich solche gelegenheiten bieten.
Jetzt gucken wir mal ob sie auch am schopfe gepackt wird.
Ja es gibt also die können natürlich nur für verschiedene werte von freiwillig das zum beispiel machen.
Zum beispiel so ja nee es gibt hier eine freiwillige app aber wenn du noch in den supermarkt reinkommen willst musst du die.
Musst du die musst du die musik die freiwillige app installiert haben.
Da gibt's natürlich eine reihe an möglichkeiten wie jetzt quasi staatliches wirken auf eine verbreitung der app hin pressen wollen können würde.
Somit den spaß hier den leuten auch wieder wegnehmen könnte da wo gehobelt wird da fallen ja jens späne.
Ja ich hoffe wir machen jetzt aber keine vorschläge zu gamification an dieser stelle also ich denke,
wenn die angst nicht ausreicht ich hatte ja schon erwähnt es gibt 'ne menge mitnahmeeffekte also wenn auch hier ist so ein bisschen wie mit virus verbreitung wenn einfach eine nennenswerte zahl von leuten diese app benutzt.
Dann wird das schon helfen und es steigt auch in gewisser hinsicht der nutzen steigt auch exponentiell an,
das heißt auch hier wie bei wie bei einer normalen immunisierung durch impfstoffe ja kann man im prinzip ja auch quasi die gesellschaft,
auf eine interessante art und weise immunisieren indem wir eben uns in die lage versetzen ausbruchs herde schnell zu finden und dazu ist es nicht erforderlich dass jeder ein smartphone hat und es ist nicht erforderlich dass jeder diese app am laufen hat,
aber umso mehr leute es tun umso größer ist der nutzen und dieser nutzen steigt genauso exponentiell an,
wie der virus uns bedroht.
Ich hätte noch einen vorschlag doch zur gamification in einer solchen app und zwar könnte der ja quasi.
Jetzt kommt der unseriöse teil hier.
Die einzahl der kontakte die du schon gespeichert hast könntest du ja daraus könntest du ja so ein eis level errechnen ja
und wenn du dann irgendwie drei tage niemanden getroffen hast dann fängt die app an dich so anzufeuern warte so du hast dich jetzt hier schon drei tage hast du bist du niemanden mehr begegnet so ne noch zwei tage
und du bist relation level irre mit.
Ne ganz ganz ganz schlechte idee weil dann lassen die leute das telefon einfach zu hause oder packen es in alufolie also das,
nee das korreliert man dann lieber mit den trainingsdaten und so weiter du hast dich zwar viel bewegt aber du bist den kontakten aus dem weg gegangen und so weiter keine ahnung.
Du bist du bist bei deinem du bist bei deinem spaziergang immer noch zu nah an die leute gegangen so ja okay aber okay ich denke wir.
Eine kleine eine kleine technische frage habe ich noch weil ich das ehrlich gesagt nicht genau weiß und ich weiß auch nicht ob du da genauere informationen zu hast aber diese information wie nah ist so ein beacon an mir dran.
Man die problemlos heutzutage.
Die sende stärke sollte das gerät auf jeden fall auch haben ich weiß nicht wie einfach das jetzt zum beispiel ist die also wie genau es ist die auszuwerten.
Und wie ob das jetzt nochmal anspruchsvoll wäre in sachen akku aber diese,
werden ja tatsächlich auch genutzt für indoornavigation also du es gibt anwendungszeit ecke von bluetooth beacons wo die jetzt nicht unbedingt von einem handy ausgehen sondern gezielt in einem geschäft,
positioniert sind oder zum beispiel in einem museum ja,
und du bist jetzt was weiß ich du hast irgendwie die museums app und dann bist du an dem exponat xy und die app sagt er hier du siehst gerade ja guck mal da,
exponat xy ist ja gerade in der nähe,
witze was zu dem lesen oder witze die dir das audio dazu anhören und das ist ja quasi ein anwendungszeit zweck dieser beacons.
Die auch zu einer.
Approximale von von nähe zu verwenden das heißt das ist in dieser idee und in diesem standard schon berücksichtigt dass man das tun will.
Ja gut aber selbst wenn das nicht teil des ganzen wäre irgendwann,
siehst du halt ein anderes telefon nicht mehr so und wir hatten ja auch schon eingangs ausführlich dargestellt
es geht ja auch um die eine gewisse verweildauer et cetera das heißt nicht jeder an dem wir jetzt vorbeigerannt wirst ist sozusagen unbedingt dann sofort
merkst du dir also man könnte es ja auch dahingehend optimieren dass man irgendwas sozusagen auch zweimal sieht bevor man sich überhaupt merkt ne weil sonst würde er wirklich jeder an dem du vorbei rauscht
gemeldet werden das sind alles so optimierung die muss man jetzt noch auch herausfinden da kann man dann irgendwie auch schön testen.
Ja aber die müssen vor allem wird es auch nicht mehr im detail diskutieren weil
natürlich wäre es du kannst jetzt sagen nur weil ich ihn bieten einmal habe merke ich mir denn jetzt nicht unbedingt ne du kannst auch einfach sagen der biegen ändert sich alle dreißig minuten.
Ich merke mir aber erst bieten es die zweimal bekommen habe der ändert sich alle dreißig minuten und wird alle.
Alle minute gesendet ich merke mir erst bieten es die ich mehr als einmal gesehen habe also das sind ja alles details das entscheidende ist dass datenspeicherung konzept.
Genau das meine ich das meine ich das meine ich genau das ist das wichtige und das haben wir jetzt glaube ich auch ausführlich dargelegt.
Denke ich auch in den shownotes haben wir dann nochmal ein blogpost indem ich das heute mal.
Auch nochmal verschriftlicht habe,
es gibt wie gesagt ein blogpost auch bei netzpolitik org der das ziemlich genau das gleiche darstellt und erklärt die haben sogar grafiken,
es gibt einen tagesthemen beitrag dazu es gibt einen beitrag in der aktuellen stunde die haben,
die grafiken von netzpolitik org genommen und die äußerungen von mir aus den tagesthemen also,
das konzept ist jetzt an an vielen stellen erläutert und mir war das jetzt wirklich wichtig dazu auch mal eine eigene sendung zu machen weil ich das wie gesagt so spannend finde ist man endlich mal so ein massen datenerfassungsbögen genomen.
Irgendwie wirklich so radikal datenschutzfreundliche umsetzen kann
und jetzt kann man die könnte man ja immer noch sagen wenn jetzt dann das robert-koch-institut sagt er könnte er uns nicht irgendwie noch mehr geben dann kann man da auch noch so doppelte
zustimmungsrate möglichkeiten geben dass jemand sagt ok komm wenn ihr wollt könnt ihr meine daten
haben und dann werden die auch offen gelegt aber da müssen die anderen auch nochmal zustimmen um die offen zu legen das könnte man alles noch mit kryptographie lösen man kann es halt irgendwie,
immer noch verbessern und verfeinern aber das schöne ist dass man hier überhaupt die besten daten eben dadurch kriegt nicht die massenüberwachung zu machen das ist doch,
echt wat feines.
Die hoffnung stirbt zuletzt.
Ja genau ich bin echt also ich bin wirklich gespannt wie sie das jetzt noch kaputt machen am ende da müssen sich wirklich mühe geben.
Genau also so eine so eine so eine steilvorlage gibt's nicht oft.
Wie man daraus über den elfmeter jetzt noch irgendwie das werden wir sehen also das wird auf jeden fall spannend bleiben sie dran weil es auch nächste woche wieder heißt.
Ja gucken wir mal ob das irgendwie tor des monats wird oder der größte fail okay linus schuldigkeit getan wir,
senden dann,
ende dieser woche wahrscheinlich wieder weiter dann gehen wir auch auf das umfangreiche feedback zur letzten sendung ein und dann gucken wir mal was dann schon wieder an neuen bewegung auf dem tisch liegt.
Ja muss aber jetzt irgendwie haben wir ja eigentlich auch so ein phrasenschwein.
Oder einen neuen bewegungs daten auf dem tisch liegt bis bald ciao.
Bis dahin tschau tschau.
Hast du
virus im kampf gegen das corona virus corona virus wer hat das verabsäumt pro ist bist du die aktive community
der bundesregierung sind die durch geschalteten sporting tv in den sozialen medien auf verschiedenen homepages im radio pro sind,
formationsfest wo sind die flugblätter und die inserate die zu einer solchen kampagne dazugehören wo ist der corona virus app,
wir leben im jahr zwanzig zwanzig für alles gibt es eine app wo ist das alles und warum.
Nicht in dieser form im kampf gegen das korona virus corona
virus wo ist das virus f corona virus im kampf gegen das corona virus corona virus wer hat das verabsäumt wer ist dafür verantwortlich dass man so etwas verschlafen hat
zum beispiel eine domain wie www corona virus für sich zu reservieren das wäre ja für mich eine kommunikationsplattform der österreichischen bundesregierung wo ist das alles was werden sie alles verzweifelt suchen es gibt es schlicht und ergreifend,
nennen sie das eine gute vorbereitung ich frage die beiden minister wer hat das verabsäumt sie haben das alles verschlafen zum schutz vor dem corona virus,
corona virus im kampf gegen das corona virus corona virus,
der virus korona im kampf gegen das corona virus corona virus wer hat das verabsäumt weil das ist ja der begriff der überall gegoogelt wird und wo jeder landet,
der mühsam versucht in einer art schnitzeljagd sich informationen aus dem netz zusammen zu holen,
wo man gar nicht weiß von welcher qualität und wie aktuell diese informationen sind breaking news am laufenden band live-ticker von irgendwelchen verdachtsfällen von diesem fieber wo ist der corona virus app
sie haben das alles verschlafen es gibt es schlicht und der.
Im kampf gegen das corona virus corona wo ist der virus corona im kampf gegen das corona virus corona virus wer hat das verabsäumt.